And I do have the Epic.
Got a good bit started.
I did want to come back in there and like
OK.
refine it some more, but yes,
I'm the product manager for for Landscape
and Searchlight,
so I'll be tackling on the products for
OK.
both of those source.
I will not be taking on like the source
hub stuff.
That's still going through like the same
people as before,
but I do have some initiatives for.
New document stuff that'll probably fall
into a blended space of both, I guess.
I don't know.
Let me go find minimize the 1000 windows.
OK.
I have to find this epic that I had
drafted or started a draft.
Let's see.
I might be able to find it too pretty
This is you might, you might find.
quickly.
Let's both try and see what happens.
Oh, that's a race. Um.
You're talking about the landscape one.
Yeah, my good. Yeah, the landscape one.
That one at least is. It beat me.
Found it.
I'm in this board all the time,
so it's not fair.
That's true. I'm like, oh, I can't.
And now I find it. I found it. OK,
so I think this,
I hope it's the same ticket.
I'll just put my screen up,
make sure we're on the same page.
OK.
So this is the one you're talking about.
Yes.
Cool. All right,
so we can get rid of this. That's just
Some of the fluff that you put on the top
or got instructions. Sorry, you know,
Yeah, no worries.
fluff just to get people started.
OK.
I'll put your name here.
Wasn't sure.
Yeah.
Put my name here.
All right.
So,
so walk me through what we're trying to
do.
OK, so let me show you. Um,
I know you got that pulled up,
Yeah.
but I'll show you some Figma. Uh,
what we're trying to do is like a blended,
That would be helpful.
like a blended.
Little bit different than what we've been
doing.
So I don't know if it's gonna like fly if
we have certain standards or if it's OK
to go away from some of the standards,
but we wanted to create a landscape
experience that has a I insight sprinkled
throughout.
And where this will just take a second to
load because it always does.
OK.
I'm going to jump in here.
Yes.
Big Figma might be suffering a little
from their own success.
Yeah.
Good problem to have.
You would think something that, yeah,
not not for me right now.
This is and anytime I try to open
something else, it stalls out.
Black screen. Um.
That's fine.
So I think some of it's going to be like
machine learning and AI. I don't know.
I don't even know.
The team has already been asking like,
how do we do any of this? I don't know.
Yeah.
Your guess is as good as mine.
I don't know how we bring all this
Yeah.
goodness into our product, really.
Just gonna stay frozen. Awesome. Yeah, OK.
Yeah.
I can help you figure that out.
What do I get for clicking too fast?
I hope this one will work. OK,
so if I've got my dashboard.
Alright.
I haven't opened this prototype in like a
minute, so.
So just to level set,
make sure we're on this.
So landscape is the module that basically
just has all the higher level stats about
Yes.
what is what has happened.
Payer backbone.
So landscape is just the payer backbone,
I hear back then.
which is different than market access
analytics,
which has a layer of coverage and
restrictions that we don't have.
So this is.
Less data than that,
and it's strictly focused on insured
lives.
Let me pull something else up too for you
then. Where'd my bar go?
Bird lines only. OK.
So when you say he doesn't have coverage,
it doesn't have details about like it.
It'll tell you that the person is covered,
but it doesn't tell you PA step therapy,
that kind of stuff, OK.
It does not. So this is a good slide.
So what can you see in landscape?
You have access to like the payer
organizations, the types, their hierarchy,
Hmm.
their relationships.
You have formulary and plan information,
but just like what are the formularies
and what are their designs?
And what are the plans?
So it's not like specific details that
are within the plans or within the
formularies. It's just what are they?
How many people are insured through them?
What kind of, you know, are they?
What's the channel?
So is it like Medicare lives?
And then even then we have different
lives types.
So dual eligible is people that are
eligible for both Medicaid and Medicare.
Low-income subsidy means that they are
getting subsidies from the government for
their healthcare. Self-insured,
self-funded and fully funded are
different models for mostly commercial
for not mostly they are for commercial
plans.
So is the employer,
I think if they're like taking on the
cost or is are are they just paying the
insurer?
So it's like that like do different types
of insured models. We also have geography.
So what is the state distribution,
the county distribution of lives and it's
really that.
Like where are the people and who are
they going through for coverage? Um.
OK. Yeah.
And the reason that this is at a higher,
this is less information than market
access analytics is standard versus
premium or something like that, right?
Like why?
This is more it's a different persona.
So the people that look at landscape are
Why don't you have that information here?
OK.
account managers.
So they are the people that manage the
relationship with the payers and this
helps them with their planning.
So like if they're if they have different.
Account managers that are focused on
large accounts or if they have account
managers that are focused on payers and
specific geographies,
they can see like kind of like what their
patient access holistically is going to
be like they don't need the details,
they just need to know like.
The who, the what and the where, right?
So it's more more about targeting and
OK.
research and knowing what's going on with
the payer. So it's let.
OK, so knowing that you're covered,
but there's a prior auth,
there's too much information for them.
At this at at this level, yeah.
OK.
So it's um.
OK.
Yeah, like who are the key organizations?
How are they structured?
That's not even coverage,
just more enrollment.
So that's a typo enrollment,
what enrollment looks like across payers,
geographies and channels.
So if you know that you have a good
OK.
example is like if I know that my therapy
is.
In the like cosmetic space,
then Medicare isn't a channel for me.
So I don't really care about they're not
going to get coverage.
So I'm not looking at like the Medicare
lives.
I'm going to be looking more for
commercial lives,
like who are the payers that are big in
the commercial space because those are
going to be the payers.
That I want to build relationships with
and then probably I want to have more
account managers focused on California or
Florida or New York or wherever people
Right.
are getting like a lot of cosmetic
treatments.
OK.
So it's that.
It's not so much like do I have good
coverage or not?
And I'm sure it comes into play at some
point,
but it really is like about the
relationships, so.
OK, that that's helpful.
Yeah.
So it's just a little bit of a different
context. So is this the right one? Yeah.
So what we want to do in landscape is we
want to have like deeper insights here.
So it's not just like hard numbers and
statistics,
it's like what's going on behind the
numbers.
So if I see a trend,
I want to know like what's driving the
trend and this is actually a pared down
version of this,
but some of these hover states where to
go like something like this.
I want to see the data point,
but what we want to do is like put blurbs.
In there to kind of summarize in in a
couple sentences.
Something that's going on in the market
and I'm trying, I wish I had.
I'm trying to see if I can find like a
good example of that. Maybe I won't.
Maybe it's better if I go to this one.
So.
We have these popovers.
Here this is a good example.
So like this,
like where we just want to give like a
little blurb,
like Centene's total enrollment lives,
enrolled lives declined by 3.1%,
driven primarily by Medicaid.
In these states,
commercial lives remain flat.
So it's just like a little synopsis.
So if I'm hovering over something in one
of my charts,
I get get a data point about that.
And it should be responsive to like the
filter selections.
So if I'm narrowing something down,
I want whatever detail I get here to be.
Based on what am I hovering on?
And what did the user filter for to give
some of those insights?
So that's like one type of summary.
Ask a couple couple questions about that.
Sorry.
Sure.
So um.
Yes.
But this one is from.
And this one's from this chart.
Yeah, I was trying to like,
which one is that one?
OK, OK, let me look at this.
So if I'm looking at a row for Centene,
this channel breakdown is showing the
OK.
distribution and we have a trend.
So it's like just taking a look,
OK.
synthesizing the data.
OK, can you go back to the little blurb?
Yeah.
So is all of the information that's in
this blurb also present in the chart,
whether it's clear, obvious,
or connected or not? In other words,
do we have to go somewhere else to get
information to populate this?
Yeah,
we'd probably want to look at the data
behind it.
It isn't necessarily like because I know
there's widget wise,
so I could click on that and then it
summarizes what's visible, right?
And I think this is a little bit of a
So I mean,
we can walk through this example, right?
different lens, so.
Um.
So declined by 3.1%.
I think that's in the chart driven
primarily by Medicaid redeterminations in
Georgia, Ohio and Pennsylvania.
I assume that's in the data,
whether or not it's presently displayed
because I can filter by states.
Commercialized. Yeah,
commercialized remain flat.
Right, that's in the data.
That should be simple with losses in
small group plans.
I don't know what that means or what. OK.
That's a data type,
so it's like the live the small.
There's a fully funded small group.
That's a category.
OK,
and that is another filter criterion that
I can use in the application.
It is and so is the ASO.
That's another lives type.
OK.
So this is like fully funded small group
and then this is self insured.
So those are both data points that we
have.
Got it. OK.
Medicare Advantage saw modest gains in
Florida and Texas should also be there
while exchange enrollment rose due to.
That's a plan type. Mm-hmm.
Yeah,
so that exchange enrollment rise and the
expanded silver tier offerings are also.
Plan types and channel, Yep.
In the data, yeah.
So everything that is described,
all the information that is presented to
the user is in one way or another present
in the data that feeds the landscape UI.
Yeah, and since this is a sample,
there are there is a little bit of
embellishment there because
redeterminations you wouldn't know unless
you knew.
Current events.
And and the same rural, rural counties,
at least this specific sentence,
OK, so that's outside of what's in the UI.
but I don't think we need to go.
It would be nice to go there,
but we don't have to like we we have a
lot of data that we could extract
conclusions from just from the data.
Without the current event layer in there
and then rural counties,
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
I don't know like.
I would know what a rural county is.
Like that's not gonna be present in the
Yeah, yeah, that's.
data.
That's just like general knowledge kind
Uh, well, is it? Is it broken down? Yeah.
Is it? Is the data broken down by county?
of thing.
So I don't know where that falls.
It yeah, it will be.
They're working on it right now, but yes.
OK, OK.
So if the data are broken down by county,
then the we should be able to figure that
out.
Maybe maybe phrased slightly differently,
but the the fundamental fact that we're
not talking about big cities here should
be understandable by the service.
Right.
And then when you said, you know,
redeterminations,
would we forget about the
redeterminations of it,
would we know where you or if you or I
just sat down and looked at the data,
It's Medicaid.
that's we would know that it's changes in
Medicaid in these three states?
Correct. We would know that from the data.
Well, yeah. OK. OK. So 99.
9% of what's in this? Yeah, yeah.
Yeah,
pretty much like this is you can
extrapolate from that that just from our
lives data.
Yeah. OK. So maybe, I mean,
we should come up with some more examples
to make sure we have a a sense of breadth.
But from what I see so far,
as long as we gather,
as long as we define the right context
for what you want to show when the user
clicks or hovers on a data point.
And in such a way that it can be.
Access programmatically,
user hovers on data point.
We can grab the right context and we can
send that to an LLM with the right kinds
of questions and formatting.
It looks pretty doable.
OK, so there's that.
I've got like a couple,
so pretty much like go ahead.
It will take.
It will take a couple of seconds to
populate. Just FYI, it won't be.
So like couple of seconds is like what?
It really just depends.
It looks a bit on the data, but unless so,
there are two ways you could go.
One is you could do it on the fly.
User hovers over the thing.
You send a request to data science.
Data science, you know,
understands the data,
execute its prompt magic,
gets the response back and and sends that
back to you and that could.
Feeds right now.
be in one go,
or it could even be streamed.
So it's like,
I would think 3 to 5 seconds would
probably be typical.
The other way that you could do it is you
could pre-calculate everything.
Yeah, I thought about that.
There's a couple of spaces where I think
I don't know how realistic that is, yeah.
that makes sense and we I have some
examples of that too. For the popovers,
Yeah.
it'd probably be like a real OK,
it's something to consider.
The other thing,
a third thing you can do is cache.
So when there's this exact set of filters
and this exact data point and this user
clicks on that thing and we go and
generate that response for however long
that data is not going to change,
cache that value.
So when another user comes in and puts in
the exact same values and hovers over the
Oh.
thing, you just pull it from the cache.
I don't know how frequently that would
Three months.
I mean the data's refreshed every three
happen, how it would be.
months, so.
That's good. Well, that's not. I mean,
that's good in terms of caching being
able to help because in all likelihood
someone will hover over that exact same
data point with that exact same filter
set,
probably at some point again in the next
three months, hopefully many times.
Yeah.
But we that's something we could try and
we could and then measure if it's even,
you know you can.
Look at what's called the cache hit rate.
So for all the times that you asked for
Mhm.
this type of answer,
what percentage of the time does it go to
the cache versus get sent to the LLM to
be recalculated?
And even if it's something like 10%,
it's still going to provide some value.
OK.
Hopefully it would be more like 30%.
3.
So those are the that's the kind of
framework I'm thinking of for how we
Thanks.
would produce those answers.
OK,
I'm trying to think if there's like
another example of something similar.
To those because.
Yeah, So what? So, yeah,
let's walk through all the kind of
features that you want.
So one of them is the blurb that explains
That's one.
what's in the chart. Are there other?
Points in this dashboard where you want
to do that, or is it just on that chart?
It's not that one. It's like all of them.
All of them have something like we kind
OK.
of pared it down for the we pared it down
to meet like our current reality.
Sure, sure.
So this isn't like to fully
forward-looking.
But there are. I'm trying to see.
That's why I'm like looking around.
There is something like this.
So like this is another type of summary
that we wanna have and.
So,
so we have a concept of a payer profile.
I don't know if you've heard of that. Um,
where it's basically APDF file that we
generate like a a human goes in and and
collects like looks at all our data and
they do manual analysis and produce um.
Like executive summaries and of.
Of of a couple of things like part of it
is,
well for this one we'll just say from the
data because I do have like a longer term
vision for next year.
So this is like short term.
This is like the the near term thing that
we could do is give them a blurb when
when a user comes in,
we want to create these. I'm sorry,
let me back up.
We want to create these profiles
dynamically because because they are
human-based,
we can only create like 120 of them in a
year because of the resources that we
have and there are 350 plus organizations,
so.
If we are able to generate these profiles
dynamically with a combination of maybe
some human inputs as well as data,
we we broaden our reach and then we also
kind of like kick our competitions.
But so that's like one of the main
drivers. Yeah,
like they're they're also create,
I like that.
I like kicking ****.
they're also.
Creating them manually. So like we get to,
we update them once a year.
They used to do it quarterly.
Now it looks like they're kind of slowing
down their cadence too. And I'm like, OK,
well,
why don't we try to get ahead of
everybody and right.
Yeah.
So stage one near term is part of the
epic or the story that you have.
Is to do something like this,
which is just based on the data and and
and if I go to a profile,
I get a summary of what's going on with
lives for this payer.
And this is obviously all simulated,
but you know in this quarter there was a
decrease of insured lives and it's pretty
similar to like the little blurbs.
It should just be broader and specific to
to this organization. But it's like,
did lives decline? Where did they decline?
What drove the change?
Mm.
And it's it's that who, what, when, where,
why, right?
OK.
Is it always kind of on a quarterly view?
Yeah.
So, I mean, so, So what?
So the humans are right now doing this.
What are the inputs and outputs of that
process?
What do we give the humans and what do
they give us back?
So for the short term for this
specifically we want to do the lives.
I can open up a profile so you see what.
What we're working with.
Do I have another thing for profiles?
House.
Well,
I'm trying to think 'cause these aren't
these are the competitor profiles.
Which is not where I'm at,
so let's see if I can find a download.
I don't want to download them again.
I've downloaded so many of these
different flavors of this stuff.
OK, well,
I'm just gonna go to landscape then and
pull one.
That sounds like it'd be faster than me
trying to.
Big one up.
So,
so this project like trying to simulate
replicate this thing is more of a next
year thing.
So I guess it would be this would be part
of the other stuff that I want to do and
probably the stuff that Liz was saying.
Strong likelihood of getting the funding
for it because of like the the strategic
side like this would definitely give us a
competitive edge, but this is what we're.
So,
so so step one is that little blurb on
Little small barb, something a little bit,
yeah. So right now this document is uh.
the dashboard and Step 2 is the longer
document.
And it whatever we do probably won't be
exactly like this because it's a little.
How many pages is this? 17 pages. OK,
this document,
they we have an executive summary.
So some of it is based on research,
like human research,
where they're going out and they're
looking at what's going on.
With the payer.
So they take it from some of the stuff
they get from our data,
our our payer data,
some of it they get from there's
financial data that I guess we also
collect and then some of it is just
straight research.
So that.
So financial data that MMIT collects or
from some other part of the business?
That we collect like we have, um,
journalists.
That's.
Now it's a journalist who's doing this.
Yeah, so this is,
this is just basic like from the website,
like the publicly traded. I mean,
OK.
That got it.
just Google them, you know,
publicly traded company.
This is where their headquarters is.
Yes.
This is from.
We know how many medical lives they have
and we know how they rank based on our
data.
We know where the majority of the
enrollment is. Again,
you can extract that from our data.
You could even extract.
You could extract this from the data.
That too. This one as well.
This one's a little bit of AI think
that's kind of coming from our data.
So it's a mix.
Here's something that's coming from the
news, right?
So they hired someone as a chief
OK.
financial officer.
So this is just publicly available info.
A lot of this we could populate from our
data financial.
So this is stuff we collect.
We create graphs and charts,
do a little bit of interpretation.
Yeah, it's a mix. It really is a mix.
Mhm, mhm.
Trying to see what else is in here like
this is more.
And like press release based.
It's probably sources.
So there are some sources that we
Mhm.
probably don't collect,
but we could collect. Again,
I I don't know what we do on the data
science side of like if we only like look
inside for answers or if we combine.
Not necessarily.
Assume anything is possible.
If we combine our data.
So I mean at the surface,
just looking at this,
OK, well.
this looks like something that could be
automated to a high degree.
I would think that you would want.
You would never want to fully automate
Yeah.
this, at least not anytime soon,
because the value proposition is the
Correct. I would, yeah.
precision of what's in here, so we could.
Yeah, like some kind of validation.
I could envision there being a process
where we would like create some of this
and then maybe have like a QC process for
someone to go in and and validate what we
collected and what we want to publish
Yes.
before it actually gets out there,
before we give any kind of misinformation.
Correct. And there's information,
there's context about our business and
market dynamics and specific competitors
and stuff that the A I isn't going to
have, right.
So that may be that for a naive on a
Right, that we would have.
naive view, you might include this fact,
but when you understand the specific
dynamic with this payer, you say, well,
it'd be better to not include this.
Or something like that. So, so I could,
you know,
Mhm.
I could depending on what you know,
how many of these, you know,
I could envision creating a data science
service that automates 60,
7080% of us in terms of effort.
The question is what's it worth?
I mean, I thought so too.
I thought it would be like that,
So.
potentially a lot.
OK.
So the business that like the the
competition that we have has a
combination of both of these services.
So landscape which I just showed you and
this like their profiles and between the
both of them it's probably it's like a
$20 million business.
OK.
And.
Right now we're significantly below that.
Like our payer profiles aren't making
that kind of money just because the
perception is that what they have is
better, even though they are.
But if you talk to them,
Mm.
if you talk to people like when we did
what VOC,
they talk about the profiles and they're
always, you know, static.
Like their static PDF files,
their their PowerPoints,
Mm.
and they also have to wait for the data
to be refreshed.
They might give like a little bit of a
different lens, but I think materially.
I don't think it's anything that we
couldn't do if we wanted to automate it,
so I have a couple of examples.
Yeah, I mean,
that's a good point about it. Like,
why isn't this a dashboard that just gets
refreshed every week or whatever?
No, whoops. I didn't mean to, like,
minimize that one. I need that one.
Here we go.
So look,
you're you're pretty much getting some so
small ownership structure,
you get dollars, lives,
accreditation like that's all research
like we're doing that through landscape.
Yeah.
It just looks more modern. I don't know.
They picked different, like,
peppier colors than we did. I, you know,
you're like, we're giving the same. Like,
Yeah, I mean,
there's some design differences here,
but yeah, I mean.
is this just the brief? That's so small.
Yeah. So there are people like this.
They like simple.
Um.
I I don't even know.
I feel like there's like another one
that's probably more.
See if we can get a little bit more.
Yeah,
this one might have a little bit more in
here.
There we go.
Top five things to know.
This is all right.
OK.
This is all data we can get from our.
Mhm.
So if we're doing 20 of these a year and
the resourcing for that isn't going to
change, let's assume,
and we can do something like 80 to 100 of
these a year.
Mhm.
Um.
This one wants a little bit more.
Does that sound like a high value
proposition?
I think the value.
So I think like our person,
he spends a lot of time like putting
those documents together because he's
manually creating the charts and graphs,
which we can do through.
Like NXP components and build them into
the like part of it.
I think we can just go ahead and do it in
in product and then if we wanted to
create like an export that has more
context with it, little bit of a hybrid.
I feel like we could do more than that,
but I mean you have a number in your mind
for a reason. So like what we're.
What do you think the like?
Why couldn't we do all the organizations?
Well,
I'm so I'm just making it based on what I
see,
regardless of whether this is rendered as
a PDF or website.
I don't think that matters to data
science,
but based on what I see and the fact that
I don't know.
we want to remain.
A level of quality control.
I'm estimating that we can automate
something like 70% of this.
So given that with the same amount of
resources, if you're doing 20 a year,
you could probably do four times that.
OK. So for no.
So we could get full coverage, yeah,
So that's kind of where that.
because we're making like 120 of them now
manually.
Oh, I thought you said 20. I miss.
I misheard you 120. Got it. OK, all right.
120.
120, yeah, so 120,
if we could like do make more
efficiencies in it, then yeah,
we probably could do all of them.
Yes. So with this, I think with the same,
so it's triple essentially. So I think,
yeah, as long as we, yeah,
that sounds realistic to me.
That'd be awesome.
Uh, yes.
The one one is getting the data,
defining what the data are,
combining the internal and the external
data in a way that's that is presented in
the right way for the user persona,
getting it in the right output.
And you know this,
I'm just talking about what's going on in
data science.
And then delivering that output to some
sort of quality control format,
whether that's PowerPoint or a website or
whatever.
And then there would be a QC process and
then there would be if it becomes a web
app, a rendering process.
Right.
I my my thoughts on this is that this
would be a pretty big lift and it's not
like a you're gonna get it done in three
months.
It's probably gonna be more like 6 to 8
and I don't know if I'm underestimating
Yeah, I mean, six months is a reasonable,
you know, blind dart at the wall.
it.
But how many,
how many of these do you have?
How many historical examples do you have?
A lot. I don't know. We've got a couple.
We've been doing this for a while. Yeah,
1005 hundred 100010 thousand like 1000.
something like that.
Um, maybe I'll have to dig around,
but I mean, it's possible that, yes,
Hundreds.
I would say hundreds.
Yeah, that's that's precise enough.
It's not five.
It's the main thing I was trying to
establish. So yeah, so yeah, I mean,
Correct.
I think, I think there would be.
I mean,
I wouldn't really call that training data.
I would call it sort of like
understanding and evaluation data because
this for the historical ones,
in order to really treat it like training
data,
you would have to recreate the state of
the data at the time that it was produced.
Which would be very difficult for
anything Internet related.
How do you update the state?
How do you reproduce the state of the
Internet five years ago?
But it's it's understanding data,
it's evaluation data and and this would
be I think a project where there would be
quite a bit of like we could produce a
first version.
And there would be quite a bit of back
and forth.
To really refine and and get it to the
quality that needs to be more so than the
other, the blurb example where if we had,
you know, 50 good examples,
Yeah, yeah.
we defined very clearly when and where it
was going to happen.
We defined very clearly.
Where they say source data,
data science could run with that and then
Mhm.
come back and show you the results.
Yeah,
let me try to find some of this other
stuff. So that's.
One one of two.
But two things so far, the blurb.
The second thing is the PDF.
And let's just assume for now that the
the little blurb,
the summary at the top of landscape is
just a summary of that PDF.
Yeah, I think it pretty much. It's just,
yeah, I mean,
we could make it pretty formula formulaic.
Yeah.
LLM are great at summarizing.
So if you have,
if you have that document and that and
that 17 page document is good and it says
what you want to say,
producing a A5 sentence summary of that
should be pretty straightforward.
5.
OK.
Let me try to think of what else I talked
about in that session.
Or maybe I can find the the PowerPoint
for our roadmap for. Oh,
I did have it pulled up. That's helpful.
The other stuff and I wish I had it more
hashed out.
Find my part on market access.
It's for Searchlight,
like we've got some new document types
and I feel like you've worked with um.
Feel like this is a thing that you guys
have done before,
just different documents. Where is this?
OK, found it.
I don't own all of these things,
just a couple of them. So Searchlight.
Maybe it's not in here. Custom spine.
Not that one. Not that one.
I have too many things in my brain, so.
Yeah, no sweat.
Document. OK,
document and market trend analysis.
I was like, what is the thing again?
So with Searchlight, we get,
we collect like millions of documents,
millions of documents.
And one of the things that we've talked
about is like trying to extract insights.
Based on those documents, things like.
If there's a large influx of changes to
oncology,
and I'll I'll work on writing all this
stuff up like a large influx of changes
to oncology. Um.
Coverage at a certain point in certain
time in the year,
then one could presume that there was the
medical boards or the review boards were
doing their evaluations of those oncology
drugs prior to that.
It's like we like extracting like more or
less when.
The payer organizations are looking at
certain things based on the changes we
see in the documents.
Does that make sense?
Yes, are making.
I would let me rephrase that last bit a
OK, that's like.
little bit when the.
Payer decision to the controllers.
I think that's the term we use when the
That's one of, yeah.
control are making decisions,
making or updating decisions.
That.
OK.
Yeah.
So OK.
That's one of them.
So there's a in trends.
So if there's like certain sentiment that
you can kind of extrapolate from
documents, that kind of thing.
So if we notice.
Certain shifts towards certain therapies.
Let me go find more resources.
Little fuzzier on this one.
Basically just trends, trends, timing,
changes in sentiment based on like the
output that we're seeing there that like
analyzing those documents and trying to
extract insights from them that we could.
Um, put out there as.
Yeah, just market trend analysis really.
Like that's the whole high level concept
as an addition to Searchlight.
So not just like alerting on documents,
Yeah.
but like what's going on in the market
based on what we're seeing from those
documents.
Yeah, I mean, so it's a little fuzzy.
Yeah, but that's OK, but.
It is fuzzy.
And I think the I think one challenge is
going to be.
Um.
Trying to replicate.
So what we should try to do is we should
try to replicate what a human analyst
would do, right?
Get a human analyst with the right
contacts,
the right knowledge of the business,
the right industry understanding,
and they had time to read 1000 documents,
which they don't.
They don't.
Exactly.
And that's the value proposition of using
a I. They had time.
If they had time to read all these
documents,
what would they extract out for a sort of
one-page list of bullet points or
something like this?
A1 slide kind of overview of what's
happening.
Which is very open-ended, right?
So we can come up with lots of example.
There are kind of kind of a couple of
approaches.
I think one of them is we can create lots
of examples and use those examples to
help the LLM under to help the understand.
What insights looked like?
1 disadvantage of that is that it will
tend to create things that look like
those examples.
Whereas a human analyst,
ideally a good one,
would find novel types of things that may
not look like previous examples.
Yes.
So by Q3 we will extend search,
search and monitor policy to identify
alert for market trend.
We'll do this by taking the data over and
collect it and to send it into patterns
and checks.
Right.
So what we would want so that there are
two good examples in here.
One of them is when we think a P&
T committee has reviewed or updated its
guidance.
And it's a it's a guess, frankly,
and you don't know that right from this
It's a gas.
data. It's a guess. That's fine,
but because the guesses can be valuable
or how perilanguage is shifting around
certain product categories industry wide.
So in order to do it.
Um, I think we would need to enumerate
At least the the list of those things
that at least covers 80% of what we would
expect to see.
That's going to be the challenge is that
the LLM is going to have a hard time.
The LM doesn't work in our business,
doesn't have the context that you have,
A minute.
right?
So it's going to have a hard time
understanding.
It has great general knowledge,
but you need to channel that general
knowledge.
Into a specific task,
and so this specific task requires
knowing what's a valuable insight and
what's not a valuable insight.
And so we would want to enumerate a list.
I see two things there.
Can we enumerate a list of those types of
things?
That would cover the bulk of what we
would hope to see out of this.
There may be millions of edge cases.
We shouldn't worry about the edge cases.
Right.
We should worry about the the 80% of the
and then the second,
That's helpful.
the second thing would be.
Again,
just a QA type approach where we we we go
wide on what we gather. So with sorry,
let me step take one step back.
With that approach we could go pretty
narrow on what we gather with the idea
that it would be right,
it would be right and valuable.
most of the time.
It'll be right almost all the time,
and it'll be valuable most of the time.
Another approach would be to go wide on
what we gather and have a human edited
down,
which should be a lot quicker than going
through and creating it obviously,
but would require some level of effort
and there might be 304050% of what we
return might be noise.
But if it's, you know,
2 pages of bullet points and they want to
get it down to five bullet points,
how long does that really take?
OK. I mean,
I I know there's definitely research we
So just kind of two different approaches,
yeah.
need to do. I'm thinking like, OK,
so one thing is like, OK, great,
we've got like 2 examples of things that
people would want to know.
Certainly there are a lot more.
So we need to probably do some research
Yes, I'm sure there are, yeah.
about like the different people that are
using Searchlight and the different like.
If they're they're alerting,
they're getting alerts on different
product classes,
so it wouldn't hurt to get an idea of
like certain product classes and just do
a little bit of research on our side to
like understand OK like.
What do I want to know as a person using
search like getting the alerts?
Like what kind of insights am I
interested in?
We have a few ideas we need to like
really dial in like specifically,
like more specifics.
Like is it PNT committees? OK, fine,
we can do a lot of research on that.
What other things do they want to know?
And then do the documents we have answer
those questions? And so, yeah,
probably a little bit more research and
synthesis of examples of what we could do
here,
because we know that as we're collecting
so many things,
there's probably a lot that could be
taken from that.
Just being more specific about what that
is as well as the role in the context.
Yeah.
Mm-hmm. I mean one.
And how I can help them?
Like what kind of guidance could we get?
Or not guidance but.
Yeah, I mean one among other research,
I wonder if it would be helpful to give
Think of that pointed.
the the user a space on the UI to tell us
somehow. So for example,
something like we're building out our A I
capabilities,
Mm.
tell us what insights you would like to
see automatically from this data or
something like that.
8.
Yeah.
OK.
To augment the like actually going,
you know the the research.
So that was a fuzzy one,
but it is a valuable one. Um.
OK, yeah, we can work with fuzzy.
You know, the challenge,
the the fundamental problem with fuzzy
will always be knowing when we're done.
Yeah.
And so as much as possible upfront,
we will want to define concrete, you know,
acceptance, success criteria,
whatever you want to call them,
things that we would observe to say,
all right, we're done. So for example,
if you let's say you come up with 20
things, we might create criteria that say.
When these things are present in the in
the data,
we capture 80% of them and of the things
that we capture,
95% are correct and error free,
something like that.
Yeah, I think those are like the third.
Otherwise,
you just keep going and you just keep
going and you just keep going.
Yes, we need to like narrow it down,
be specific and then we could probably,
I'll have to think about that one.
I haven't really had a lot of time to
Yeah, sure, of course.
And it can vary by insight too.
It can be like if this insight,
this is the one most valuable.
think about that one.
If this insight isn't there,
you have to get it.
Whereas if this other type of insight is
there,
if you get it at least 60% of the time,
that's good enough.
You know there could be.
Nuance to how we define that.
Could we, I mean,
is this like an opportunity for AI chat
as well?
Or would that be riskier based on?
um Why is that better than just telling
them what we already know they want to
know?
Well,
there's there's probably two parts of it,
right? Like there's that.
And then I just wonder if it's like
supplemented with AI chat.
You tell me.
Yeah, I mean, I said it sort of depends.
I mean, I think that.
Um.
Asking, asking for those kinds of trends.
So a chat bot that is focused on trends
over the last three months in across
thousands of payer documents.
Probably a lot more than that.
Hundreds of thousands of pair documents
where worth is going to be.
It's going to be challenging to get.
Well, so looking at these two examples,
when are P&
T committees making decisions and that
and we identify that by.
You know, point in time,
substantive changes in coverage for some
therapeutic area across payers.
Mm-hmm.
It's that across payers bit that's going
to be tricky. It's not impossible,
but that could be doable.
The the where you want to go and you want
to interrogate a specific document or a
small set of documents, it's very doable.
When you're trying to look at big lots of
big data flow,
To have chat so.
then it's a lot more challenging.
When you're trying to look at lots of and
and you're trying to count things,
that's literally the thing.
When you want to count things across big
swaths of documents is where chat is not
really chatting directly with the
documents.
It's not going to be very successful if
you build an intermediate layer,
more work that says that calculates.
Certain facts across documents, well,
which is essentially landscape, right?
Then then it becomes much more doable.
So if there are APIs in landscape where
we can retrieve data,
customer asks a question,
we can go retrieve data, give them,
but then you're just essentially showing
them what's in landscape and you're
making them type words in instead of
clicking buttons.
So, so, so I would say,
so think about this and and I would say
Yeah.
come up with a list of maybe 10
prototypical questions that you think a
user after seeing landscape after seeing
searchlight.
After seeing the diff of the changes or
whatever,
and after seeing the 10 key 10 or 20 core
inside type things that we extract,
what's remaining for them?
What do they still need that isn't
satisfied by each of those things?
And if that's substantive,
then we look at how to solve it.
OK.
And we might solve it with one of those
other ways, or we might solve it by chat.
You know,
I would focus more on the problem than
the solution quite yet.
I'm with you. Yeah, I get that.
It hasn't been one that I've sat with
long enough to, like,
really have a good feel for it.
The landscape one I have sat with for a
while and I I mean,
Yeah, sure. Yeah, that's fair.
I've had that product for a lot longer,
so for so.
That one's a new one and then we have
like the standard stuff.
So I know we did some stuff for document
types like researching new document types.
Were you involved in that?
Uh, for Searchlight.
For Searchlight.
Yeah,
I remember I'm I'm sort of loosely
involved in Searchlight,
so mostly Sophian and Fran are just
running with it.
And so I don't intervene there,
OK.
mostly because they just don't need my
help. They're they're fine.
They know how to define things.
They work really well with the team.
So I try to focus my attention on areas
where the work needs more definition
before people can do it.
Got it.
So if we need more of that more document
types that we want to take a look at like
is there do we go through this process as
well to funnel it through or?
I would say no,
because it's really for new product
development and what you're talking about
is ongoing product development or new
Actually.
feature development. So I would say,
you know,
define what new document types you want,
write it up,
put it in a queue and then see how it
stacks against the other work that his
team is doing.
OK, that works. All right. Um,
did she mention?
Yeah, what? Out of curiosity, what?
What document types are you?
Because I know there's Excel and PDF.
What else?
Oh no, no. This is for Searchlight.
There's a it's document types.
It's more like like PA forms or.
Oh, God, yeah, yeah, I understand. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah.
Formulary stuff like there's additional
ones we want to add in like we have a set
right now and there's others that we want
to add into the mix and I think that
Right.
would follow like the same process that
we used for the other.
Yes.
The previous ones is just a continuation
of expanding the types of documents we
Yeah, yeah.
collect.
So it doesn't really feel like it's.
It's not NPD, it's just.
Yep, absolutely.
It's just continuing feature expansion
and improvement of the service, yeah.
Right. And then the other stuff is that.
So we've got like the market trends from
Searchlight. There's also,
I don't know because so I've got the
landscape stuff with the insights.
I think there's probably opportunity for
widget wise incorporation as well,
which I haven't done any of that yet,
but we have all these widgets.
There's the insights I want to sprinkle
throughout the experience,
and then there's the pair profiles I want
to build like that.
That's kind of like the linear
progression for landscape with more
intelligence in it. There's we.
So we did a hackathon project for a.
Scenario simulator.
Did Liz bring that up at all or did she?
Mhm.
Was she specific about what projects? OK,
that one she got really excited about,
No.
OK.
so it is more kind of like building a
bridge between.
Our products,
so taking an alerting system like
Searchlight,
identifying something and then telling
giving insights as to what you could do
about it,
like approaches you could take in
response to the type of alert you got.
And then there would be like a little bit
of forecasting as well to say like, OK,
if you took this type of,
if you acted on this remediation,
it could tentatively have this kind of
output.
So we'd be looking at our historical data
to see, well,
a lot of things that one's like that one
feels heavier.
Beer as far as like the amount of pieces.
Can you walk me? Can you walk me through?
Can you walk me through a specific
example of what that might look like?
Yeah, I can. I have a. I have a.
Have a deck for that, so that was our.
Great.
Um.
Let's pull that guy open.
That one's not an 8 minute conversation,
but it might be. We'll see.
This is just an intro, right?
Gotta see what we've got going on.
I had Piper. I love it.
Yeah, as a team. So Mark,
you know they're they need to make quick
informed decisions in a dynamic
fragmented pair workspace.
So like let's see the product concept is.
Not important. Um.
Yeah, so you get the alerts.
Of market and high impact market events,
pre-populated scenario builder.
So we want to use some AI to like hold on,
let me show you see if there's something
better that I could show you that's going
to give you more like this. OK,
Thumbs down. I'm looking at it.
Thumbs down.
so Medicaid. Yeah, huh. Yeah, bad news.
Medicaid cuts.
Medicaid cuts in New York could shift HIV
coverage and threaten access to Bigtarvy
Not happy.
like that's the notification that you got.
So the idea is you get an alert and then
OK.
add targeted intervention to the playbook
like that's what you want to do because
you know there's a 10% drop.
So the idea is, oh God,
you're gonna laugh. I did it. Clever.
You had fun. That's what counts.
I did. Well,
I think I was delirious at that point.
What?
So we we spent a lot of hours on this.
So you come to a page as a template and
then this tool like AI would pre populate
some things that you like.
Preconfig some stuff and then also tell
you why it set it.
So your trigger was there was a funding
reduction for HIV.
So there was some detail that we got and
that this type of event happened
historically.
And then this is like we have like a
OK.
trend of what happened after that event
happened.
Maybe again this is the hypothetical.
Scenario. So you fill out like, OK,
if these things are true,
what's the percentage of change in
eligible lives?
Like what would happen based on this
change?
Person can come in in here and make some.
So they're they're running a simulation.
OK.
And.
Again,
some of it's based on historical data.
So we know like something took place and
then after that event certain things
happen,
like numbers dipped in certain
percentages.
And we have a lot of historical data that
we could pull from to extrapolate some of
that.
So we know what potential churn would be
based on that historical data.
So we could predict under certain similar
circumstances.
You could anticipate like this kind of
similar output.
Okay. So keep going.
And because.
Because these are subject matter experts,
they would also know based on their own
personal experiences going through
similar events,
which is why it's not all driven by a I.
It's also like, OK,
we're drawing some conclusions like what
you what could happen.
But they can also say like,
actually I've never seen it did that much.
So I think it's more like a instead of.
Dropping 10%, maybe only dropped 5%,
that kind of thing.
So like the human's still in the seat
where they can take control of that and
then we see an output of what the what
that scenario looks like 2 months from
now, six months from now, a year from now.
What have you?
And I haven't looked at this in a while
OK.
either.
So should have prepped um.
No worries.
So we've got the lives impact,
certain kinds of scores.
We we could do some of those calculations,
but it's like this stuff here.
So you have certain types of risks based
on a market event. Let me see.
Yeah,
I think I was delirious 'cause I'm
looking at it now and I'm like,
what do we do here?
Setting benchmarks is something I can do.
Um.
Let me see if I can find.
I'm trying to think of like certain types
of interventions.
So if you know there's going to be a drop
in access to something,
typically you're going to go out and talk
to you,
you create like a patient access program.
You want to go get out there and talk to
your payer account.
Like there's certain things you could do.
You could negotiate better coverage.
If you had better coverage,
then your reach would increase.
How much would my reach reach be
increased by? Well, X percentage. Why?
Because historically if I have like the,
you know,
we see this type of coverage for this
kind of drug.
This is the kind of reach that it has at
the end of the day, things like that.
So it's like a lot of like looking at
market events and historical data.
Yeah. So on the surface, I think that's,
yeah, I think I get the concept,
That's super fuzzy, but.
but it would require building a very
robust coverage model.
Which would take into account many
factors. So you know,
status across payers, you know,
seasonality, historical changes,
Yep.
news events, I don't know what,
but it would it would require.
This is not a simple model.
Yeah, yeah, it doesn't mean it's. Yeah,
it doesn't mean it's impossible.
That's what I said. I'm like,
this is not a simple thing by any stretch
of the imagination.
This is gonna take a while to do.
But you know, I would imagine,
and this is fuzzier than everything else
I've said so far today,
I would imagine that it would be,
it should be possible given.
Access to the right data and a good
definition of, you know,
what's if a human's going to make this
prediction,
what data are they going to sit down and
they'll look at? You know,
probably you could produce something
that's good, but not amazing.
I could I've seen models like this get
into the like 60 to 75% kind of accuracy
range and obviously that goes down.
You know a three-month prediction is
Yeah.
going to be more precise than a nine
months prediction.
So but that can be you know you can make
recommendations on so then.
Cracks, yeah.
That model would have anything that
you're going to recommend would have to
be a knob you turn in that model, right?
And so the way that you would be able to
recommend something based on increasing
the number of lives is you turn all those
knobs in various directions,
you see what make the numbers of lives go
up in the model.
And then you can say, hey,
and you can say, you know, yeah,
You got a thumbs up there.
I think there's a there's a cool.
Somewhere there's a cool like firecracker
thing, fireworks thing, yeah.
I liked it and like,
I don't think I have that.
So it would be complicated. It would,
it would be, you know,
complicated but doable was the way I
would say.
This is definitely a large effort that
would produce something getting good,
That's what I suggested.
probably at a good but not blow your mind
away level of quality.
But you know, again,
it just depends on the value proposition.
Yeah.
Sometimes a prediction that's 51%
accurate provides value,
and sometimes it doesn't.
Yeah, I have to do a refresher of this.
Like, I can't tell you.
Yeah.
It feels like this didn't even happen
that long ago.
Hackathon didn't happen that long ago,
but it feels like it was a lifetime ago.
Yeah, I know how you feel. Yeah. OK,
so we could, yeah.
Things have been crazy. I like,
I can't remember and I know it was good.
Yeah.
But yeah,
we wanted to do like confidence scores as
Yes.
well and transparency of like how we
extrapolate the data.
Because I think a lot of problem,
like a lot of people struggle with AI
because of the whole black box.
Like how did you draw this conclusion?
Yes.
So we wanted to build something that
would have the transparency and then also
Transparency. Yep.
like give you the controls because.
I mean,
there's a lot of risk in doing something
Yep.
like that, right? Because if they like,
listen to whatever recommendation you
gave and it doesn't go well,
then uh oh so.
Yeah, yeah.
Something that I found is is giving
evidence.
So not necessarily evidence from within
the model, but related evidence.
So to give you a quick example,
I worked on a peer reviewer recommender
before.
So based on the this paper submission to
this journal,
which experts are most likely to complete
a peer review?
For this paper, not eligible,
but actually most likely to complete and
then to give so that you can then reach
out to them to give evidence.
What we would do is we would go and find
keywords from their last five papers and
just put that on screen and that and
that's completely outside the model,
but it shows the user, hey look,
this person is an expert.
In this field and other kind of similar
things. So yeah,
absolutely evidence is extremely valuable.
Yeah,
so that one I think is flashy and
exciting and everything,
but we'd have to do like research on a
lot of things and I could envision it
being I I told this like this would need
Yeah.
a whole new development team and probably
a lot of people that could like test it
Sure.
and.
Write these scenarios like it would be
really heavy on the.
Like it would need dedicated data
scientists and probably for a while like
Yeah.
this would I could see it going for like
a year.
It's a big swing.
It is.
Yeah, doesn't mean we shouldn't do it,
but it's a big swing.
Yeah.
Yeah. OK. Well,
looking forward to outcomes of.
Shoot me a message. Yeah,
like shoot me a message of like next
steps, like what I need to give you.
I know I need to write up like the other
stuff that's like a little bit closer,
a little more grounded and closer to like
OK.
what we can deliver based on what we have.
And then maybe even next steps for this
sucker like that would be really helpful.
But yeah.
OK.
Really sort of dive into OK.
5.
Yeah,
the the landscape ticket is like nearest.
And and probably more critical,
the one that I already started filling
Yeah.
Right, right. OK, cool. Thanks, Vicky.
out, OK.
Thank you. That was super fuzzy.